'l'annonce d'une pause dans la carrière
du groupe beatty est ce phénomène de la
pop sud-coréenne a fait plonger leurs
labels à la bourse de séoul depuis neuf
ans le groupe génère des milliards de
dollars pour l'économie sud-coréenne
leur label a tenté d'atténuer
l'information assurant que les sept
garçons continuerai à travailler
ensemble
mardi ils ont annoncé faire une pause
pour poursuivre leur carrière en solo
lui voit la vie en rose ryan gosling
interprétera kent dans le film barbie
les studios warner viennent de diffuser
la plastique de l'acteur cheveux
peroxydés abdos parfaits et qu'elles
sont bien nommés une photo partageur
masse par les internautes dont certains
n'hésitent pas à se moquer en le
comparant à près de danse kouilou c'est
un canard sauvage très commun dans
l'hémisphère nord le capuchon verts qui
donne son nom à ce canal est observé
chez les mâles pendant la période
nuptiale le plus beau seulement ouï
dire par là
tel est le message
ça c'est quand même extraordinaire
regardez regardez voilà c'est c'est un
bien de se marier après tout j'ai dit
voilà je précise quand même qu en début
d'émission quand elle m'a vu arriver
elle a dit à stéphanie elle a 10 ans
j'aime pas du tout quand il porte cette
veste
allez je l'enlève vous savez quoi
regarder ohlala non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un monsieur michel très bien le
bout la chemise elle était dans le
panier à linge sale et vous avez mille
fois raison
moi je suis classe je suis pas un
charlot happy new fear
merci ça commence bien et pour
accueillir ces nouveaux clients le
camping a pensé à tout
1 et le petit cadeau
voilà que vous avez été sages vous avez
droit à du rosé bouteille c'est pour toi
et puis pour madame j'ai un cadeau
qui quittent ménage avec les pompes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça c'est mon
cadeau
[Musique]
et
puis on va surtout observer ses pieds et
s'il ya le moindre souci aller consulter
très rapidement puisque plus est pris
tôt et moi ça s'installe du couple un
solution pour rim mais on est tous
contents et ne transpirent jamais son
décodeur
les amis c'est comme les étoiles s'étend
dans la nuit on peut du coup
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête dans chaque bon ça casse pas
dis pas tu es 2e ou 3e ou 4e
la boussole à l'époque on appelait
avec fabrice et l'amour dans une
direction c'est clair tout droit n'a pas
de carrefour y'a pas d'intersections n'y
a pas de rond point c'est
[Musique]
[Rires]
moi je pense que c'est pédagogie il aide
les âmes égarées qui savent pas où elles
vont je suis un arbre en voyage ou du
mes racines ce sont mes branchés sont
plaintes et dans le ciel mais vous
m'avez donné envie de plaintes et mes
racines dans votre terre de charente
d'accord du francis maintenant on va
aller à londres et on va boire un petit
verre d'eau et ça fera du bien à tout le
monde bonne soirée bretonne fleury jolie
roncier en braille au défi ce d'océan
aux faux abeilles fille dévoué perles de
miel teinté de vent aujourd'hui
l'émission la de ce jour c'est la 200e
un magnifique gâteau qui a été croquée
[Musique]
c'est ça donc mon cher olivier très bon
anniversaire on m'a laissé souffler ses
40 ans ça fait plaisir chez 168 2022 ça
fait 40 ans
à tous
super ça nous a donné l'occasion de
réécouter il est tellement grand alors
on fait normalement enfin plans serrés
quand on réalise des missions enfin
plans serrés sur les clés voilà donc
c'est très simple tu fait réaliser les
missions sinon c'est pas un plan serré
ça c'est un polar américain voilà ça
c'est un plan serré sur les clés voilà
merci un jeu mais aussi m'occuper de la
réalisation de l'opération c'est aussi
simple que ça va normalement quand on
fait une bonne forme voilà sur le banc
et une vanne sur les clés les mots clés
les clés sont la voilà la paroisse et à
naters assez clean d'accord ça ces
écrans voilà merci en régie vous avez
passé un bon moment relativement on
avait joué ensemble à perth a
relativement haut c'était pas super
super vous reviendrai quand même
j'espère bah ouais